around 50 defense ministers from nato
and counterparts from around the world
are meeting in brussels to discuss
military aid to ukraine u.s defense
secretary lloyd austin confirmed that
more weapons will be on their way
and i'm especially pleased to be able to
announce today that the united states
will provide an additional one billion
dollars
uh security assistance package
for ukraine
and that includes our 12th drawdown from
dod inventory since august
of 2021
and it includes guided mlrs munitions
18 more
m triple 7 howitzers
and the tactical vehicles to tow them
and thirty six thousand rounds of
one five five millimeter ammunition
and u.s army general mark miller
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
reiterated what was at stake in putin's
war on ukraine
the world has a significant stake in the
outcome
of what happens in ukraine
so-called rules-based international
order is at stake that has been in place
since the end of world war ii
to prevent great power war and to
prevent large powers
from conquering smaller countries
with military force
and we can cross over now to robert
person a professor of international
relations at the u.s military academy at
west point he is speaking to us in a
personal capacity a very warm welcome to
the day sir good to have you with us we
just heard there nato again stepping up
pledging to provide more military
support it is substantial but is it too
late
you know i think it really is important
to remember that
many of us have been predicting for a
long time that this would be a long
drawn-out conflict it's going to be a
slow slog
for ukraine not just to defend
its territory but
to
perhaps go on the offensive and begin to
reclaim much of the territory that
russia has seized since february 24th uh
and so in that respect uh you know
certainly um you know they could have
used more weaponry uh yesterday
and uh and ages ago but
at this point i think anything that the
western uh nations and partners of
ukraine can deliver to kiev to use as
quickly as possible
can only uh assist ukraine in staying in
this fight long enough
to uh hopefully begin to reverse
some of the gains that russia has made
over the last couple of months now it
does beg the question of course if this
does end up being an open-ended conflict
is western resolve sustainable
of course that's uh the million-dollar
question is just how long
the united states uh the european union
and other partners are willing to stand
by ukraine with uh meaningful
substantive but yes costly assistance uh
to uh repel the russian invasion um and
you know here i would i would go back to
uh the statement by general milley that
you just played um which is to say that
uh the implications of this fight extend
far beyond eastern europe far beyond uh
europe and eurasia and really go to the
the heart of global security and
stability that has maintained peace and
prosperity for much of the world
for the last
many many decades you know when general
milley speaks about the rules-based
international order
you know this is this is a concept this
is a construct
that has
you know benefited all of us and to the
degree that russia's actions
upset that order and threaten its very
survival um it i it's it's something i
believe that that is worth investing in
uh in in something worth fighting for
obviously uh that may be difficult for
the public's uh of these countries to
understand
and to appreciate why some of the costs
that they're being asked to bear in
support of ukraine
aren't just about ukraine but they're
about our fundamental national security
interests as well what is the picture
that is emerging right now from the war
in ukraine we're now three months
in and especially you know what
conclusions can you now draw about the
military strength of russia
so you know we've learned a lot in the
last uh in the last couple months um you
know we've learned a lot about uh both
the capabilities and the resolve of the
russian military and the ukrainian
military i think one of the things that
we've come to appreciate as russia has
abandoned its early
military objectives of seizing kiev is
that this is a conflict that
generally seems to favor the side that
is playing defense
it's relatively easier and less costly
to defend uh a square kilometer of
territory than it is to go on the
offensive and so as the fight now
concentrates in eastern ukraine in the
donbas i think it's important to take
that into account as we begin to think
about the future trajectory of
the war
to the degree that it is able i believe
that russia will try to
certainly extend its footprint in the
donbas as we're seeing um but also try
to consolidate those gains so the more
that russia is able to control and
consolidate uh occupied territory now i
think the harder it is going to be for
ukraine to displace them later i mean so
i think ukraine's efforts and by
extension our efforts supporting ukraine
really ought to be oriented towards
preventing the consolidation and further
gains of russian territory in the east
robert person professor of international
relations at the u.s military academy at
west point he has been speaking to us
today in a personal capacity sir we
appreciate your time thank you
thank you